on the season finale of Rick and Morty
mr. president some kind of alien Booga
has infested the Kennedy sex tunnels
I wanted hunted down and taken out
Kennedy sex tunnels naturally you'll
forget you saw them along with in order
of national embarrassment the Truman
cocaine lounge the McKinley hooker dump
and the Lincoln slave Coliseum he didn't
free them all the season finale of Rick
and Morty next Sunday at 11:30 hi I'm
Erik Bosse and you just watched the
preview for the season 3 finale of Rick
and Morty called the Rick tree and Morty
days okay so let's quickly break this
down and make some predictions first off
let's talk about the title of the
episode the Rick turian more debate it's
a parody of The Manchurian Candidate a
movie from the 60s and a remake in the
2000s about a communist plot to
assassinate a presidential candidate and
get an evil brainwashed commie elected
instead this seems like it could come
into play in the finale
Rick and Morty again meet the president
from the get schwifty episode but I feel
like there's more to this story than
we're seeing a lot of other promos this
season have been pretty coy making it
seem like the episode will be about
something else
for example the promo for the Atlantis
mix-up showed nothing about the Citadel
or evil Morty so I think that's what
we're looking at this episode I predict
that the president that the episode
description promised Rick would meet is
actually the newly elected president of
the Citadel evil Morty who will have
some secret plot against this president
perhaps using this infestation of googas
I'm not sure why evil Morty would need
to do that the Civil of Rick's is way
more powerful than the American
government but whatever meanwhile there
are a few loose threads established
earlier in this season than I could see
coming back remember there was Tammy and
Phoenix person resurrected in the
post-credits scene after the premiere
there's also Rick's assassin ally Jaguar
from pickle Rick The Vindicator
supernova and janitor noob noob who were
left alive in that episode and good ol
mr. poopy butthole who keeps showing up
and so cameos in recent episodes so
we'll see I have a feeling that all of
these characters could return for the
season finale the way squanch and
birdperson showed up in the season 2
finale now a few other Easter eggs in
this promo the janitor and the White
House tunnels is an animated version of
Mike McMahan who is a writer on the show
the creature that attacks them is what
the president calls some kind of alien
now googas are the semi-improvised name
of an alien in one of justin roiland and
Dan Harmon's old channel 101 shorts
crazy right that's what we're gonna call
him and just a bit of history on these
presidential scandals the Kennedy sex
dungeon is a reference to JFK's
notorious affairs notably one with
Marilyn Monroe the Truman cocaine lounge
could be a reference to Harry Truman's
vigorous round-the-clock work styles I
mean something had to be keeping that
butt from stopping the McKinley hooker
dump doesn't seem like a reference to
anything but Emily wasn't really known
to sleep around but who knows but then
right as the president stands in front
of the portrait of Abraham Lincoln he
mentions the Lincoln slave Coliseum he
didn't free them all a reference to the
Emancipation Proclamation that freed all
the slaves in this case it sounds like
they're saying Lincoln secretly forced
slaves to fight each other for
entertainment like Marvin candy and
Django Unchained or maybe this means
we'll get a comeback of another old
figure who perhaps didn't actually die
Abe Rodolphe lincoler what loose threads
do you want to see tied up in the season
three finale weigh in in the comments
below with your predictions or tweet me
directly I da boss we're following new
rockstars on Twitter at new rockstars
for updates on their videos and
subscribe to this channel for all kinds
of Rick and Morty deep dives in Theory
videos thanks for watching bye